todo cambió en
1999 con la llegada de hugo chávez al
poder venezuela históricamente aliada de
eeuu empezó a acercarse a rusia y así lo
confirman los datos desde 2006 moscú ha
prestado alrededor de 17 mil millones de
dólares a caracas que ha comprado armas
rusas en valor de 4 mil millones de
dólares así como la importación del 80
por ciento del trigo en venezuela es
ruso una cooperación económico militar
que sobre todo es vista como estratégica
el presidente nicolás maduro no dudó en
febrero en posicionarse a favor de rusia
en el conflicto con la otan y la
invasión a ucrania por eso venezuela
anuncia todo su respaldo al presidente
vladimir putin en la defensa de la paz
de rusia
desde 2019 venezuela no tiene relaciones
diplomáticas con eeuu y washington dejó
de comprar petróleo venezolano en ese
momento el crudo suponía el 96 por
ciento de sus ingresos pero la
exportación no la ocupó rusia y
actualmente el petróleo venezolano tan
solo supone el 1 por ciento de su
consumo y el 3% de sus importaciones
sin embargo desde el 5 de marzo se están
retomando diálogos entre eeuu y
venezuela y el 28 de junio una
delegación visitó caracas en el aire
flexibilizar las sanciones y los
embargos a cambio de diversificar la
obtención de crudo desde la ruptura de
occidente con rusia todo esto mientras
nicolás maduró no ha dejado de visitar
en las últimas semanas a países aliados
como irán o turquía